what do you have to prove what are you
jensen ackles so do you ever look like i
gotta prove myself
i gotta write i gotta do this or do you
do things really because you just
love those things right
yeah how many lotteries do you have to
win to be considered
success right are you are you pretty
content or are you
do you want to do more things because
you just love acting you love creating
you love producing and you want to keep
doing that or is it more like a balance
like
i got to stay in the limelight got to
stay in this got to be present got to be
relevant do you feel
any of that pressure uh sure sure
absolutely i mean there's a lot of
people asking me you know what are you
gonna do what are you gonna do what's
next what's you know what do you want to
do
um and i i yeah i i think i'd be
uh deaf and blind and insensitive if i
didn't
if that didn't at least affect me in
some way or if i wasn't like oh yeah
maybe i should
maybe i should come up with a game plan
but i've always been a
uh i've always been a you know let's
just see where the where the wind takes
me you know let's let's roll with the
punches and and see what comes down that
i mean i'm not going to sit around and
and you know wait
like i will i will be active and
pursuing things that interest me
but uh i don't uh
i try not to allow myself to feel the
pressure
that makes you know because you can you
can tell especially
with actors when they're desperate oh
yeah i can do that yeah i i i don't care
if there's a certain yeah there's a yeah
i think there's a certain odor that
comes with that
yeah and and it's if you can stay away
from that
you can be content and still stay
confident and still push
uh you know still push the the ball down
the road that i think
i think things happen for you um but
like you said
i'm uh i don't feel like i need to
reinvent myself
you know i've spent 15 years honing
a certain type of character and
and honing the skills that are needed to
do that and tell tell story
um so why not why not parlay that into
into the next uh situation
um you know somebody was like what are
you what are you gonna do are you gonna
uh you know try to do romantic comedies
are you gonna try to do something
completely out of the box you need to
try to
and sure that all sounds fun but i also
know that
um i enjoy playing
the character the type of character that
is that is dean winchester because
clearly because i've done it for 15
years and i'm not i don't want to you
know
i don't want to destroy that uh i want
his legacy to be great i want the show's
legacy to be great i've enjoyed playing
that character
right so why wouldn't i want to play a
similar character on a different stage
right so uh
you know but at the same time it's like
i don't know maybe something comes along
and
uh you know i i get a call
to go meet chuck lori and then all of a
sudden i'm on a half hour
you know that's i i'm kind of i don't
say oh this is my lane i'm going to stay
in it
but i do also understand that the
you know the the audience uh
that has been built over the past 15
years is used to see me in a certain
light
and i'm happy to stay in that light as
long as as long as it stays
lit